de la toute première console de Asus
c'est la Rogue à l'ail Rogue Ali on va
dire en français et cette rogalie elle
est elle est intéressante pour plein de
choses même si globalement la réponse
sera non et je vais vous dire pourquoi
ma réponse sera non ça peut être un peu
sévère ça peut être dur pour autant
j'aime beaucoup Azu j'aime beaucoup ce
qui présente pour moi le meilleur
smartphone de gaming aujourd'hui sur le
marché c'est le rockphone soyons clair
ils ont une superbe expérience matériel
logiciel avec un Moric White qui est
juste top ici mais il y a un petit
quelque chose qui prend pas avec cette
console aussi jolie soitet aussi sexy
soit-elle quel que soit l'expérience il
y a quelques points très bloquants très
compliqué et si Asus vient pas les
corriger pour moi ça ne pourra jamais
fonctionner
une console portative c'est quoi et bien
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut emmener
partout facilement avec soi et si la
mission est remplie vous la prenez elle
fait partie de cette génération de
grandes consoles comme l'estime decks
que vous allez emmener avec vous très
facilement avec plein de jeux à
l'intérieur super promesses très joli ça
c'est cool je l'aime beaucoup elle est
jolie elle est pas très lourde elle est
sexy elle est intéressante jusque là
tout va bien voilà la bête la prise en
main est très très bonne vous avez deux
boutons sur le haut de chaque côté au
contrôle qui sont situés juste là et
pour la main droite c'est exactement la
même chose sur les hauts très facilement
et ici avec vos quatre boutons sans
oublier à l'arrière de boutons vous
allez avoir en plus ici vous voyez donc
on est trop facilement ça c'est plutôt
bien c'est qui qui fait quoi aujourd'hui
on tient très très bien en main beaucoup
mieux qu'une switch par exemple je
trouve pas trop lourde elle fait ses 68
g donc ça c'est cool puis sur le dessus
vous avez votre prise jack micro ici
extension au micro SD votre port ici
spécialement Asus vous allez pouvoir
venir brancher le XJ mobile si besoin ça
coûte très efficace augmente vraiment
l'addition vous la recharger ici le
bouton de volume et le bouton pour rien
l'allumer l'éteindre cette console est à
plusieurs problèmes plusieurs problèmes
qui sont vraiment des points bloquants
qui font que je peux pas du tout venir
vous la recommander en l'état et tant
qu'Asus ils auraient pas corrigé ça va
être compliqué de venir vous recommander
la regali pour autant elle est cool
alors premier problème et bien je dirais
que ça va être toute l'expérience
logicielle à savoir que vous avez un
Windows à l'intérieur c'est à dire qu'en
fait vous avez une console qui n'est pas
réellement une console qui est un PC
alors effectivement c'est une console
c'est un format console on l'aura
compris bien évidemment on le voit mais
en réalité c'est un PC c'est à dire que
lorsque vous venez l'allumer et bien
vous arrivez directement sur Windows on
va effectivement République of Gamers ça
se lance très simplement petite
interface on est chez Asus Rogue et
ensuite vous arrivez pour démarrer votre
Windows très honnêtement j'appelle pas
ça une console je dirais plutôt un PC
portable en vrai tout simplement parce
que bah parce que il y a quand même pas
mal de choses à configurer tu sais c'est
pas une sorte de Plug and Play comme une
console une console tu la prends tu la
branches tu sais à quoi tu joues comme
le style d'AC par exemple bien c'est pas
le cas ici ici dès que tu de faire un
truc un peu tâtonné pour trouver les
meilleurs réglages possible et une fois
que tu as trouvé les meilleurs réglages
là tu peux vraiment profiter l'interface
d'Asus vient se lancer directement là
sauf que en fait vous êtes sur Windows
ce qui fait que si vous prenez hop là et
vous montez là vous êtes sur Windows
directement vous pouvez venir lancer un
navigateur pour aller naviguer sur
Internet vous avez votre Wi-Fi vous avez
tout donc c'est en Windows que vous avez
là alors le côté pratique c'est que vous
pouvez venir tout installer tous les
jeux de PC vont venir tourner là dessus
et comme c'est une machine qui est très
performante on va pouvoir faire tourner
des jeux qui nécessitent beaucoup de
performances c'est cool maintenant il y
a un vrai gros inconvénient ici c'est
que au lancement de la console lorsque
vous venez de l'avoir et bien il faut
venir la configurer avec ça l'interface
utilisateur elle est pas du tout
optimisée on est loin de ce que je
propose un styleck par exemple voilà où
tout est optimisé tu arrives tu branches
ça joue quoi et pourtant le style deck
c'est le meilleur aujourd'hui là-dessus
non je veux pas dire que c'est meilleur
aujourd'hui je dirais que pour le grand
public le style deck a beaucoup à
proposer sans vraiment parce qu'il coûte
quand même la moitié du prix c'est un
peu plus de la moitié mais il est quand
même vraiment moins cher
ouais ça a été prévu pour ça pour que ça
soit ultra grand public alors que là on
se retrouve avec une surcouche à Windows
ça reste du windows tu as pu le voir dès
qu'on dès qu'on essaie de conférer
quelque chose il faut faire apparaître
le caddie virtuel qui apparaît pas
automatiquement des petites choses comme
ça toute bête mais qui font que avant de
profiter d'un jeu tu as peut-être 15-20
minutes de configuration après le truc
qui est pratique c'est que comme vous
avez votre bouton en physique à Moric
rate vous appuyez et là vous retrouvez
tous vos paramètres choisissez mode
performance mode Turbo le profil du jeu
le clavier les FPS vous pouvez venir
limiter votre fréquence soit du 60 soit
du 120 Hertz vous le voyez directement
ici votre résolution 720p 1080p et puis
ensuite vous avez juste un petit bouton
sur le côté lorsque vous venez appuyer
dessus et bien ça vous lance votre
expérience Asus Rogue directement ici
avec vos différents jeux l'autre sujet
qui pour moi est totalement rédhibitoire
mais totalement rédhibitoire c'est
l'autonomie ça va Steven tu es qui alors
moi c'est Steven comme tu viens de le
dire je travaille pour signer de France
ce que tu en penses parce qu'en fait je
m'amuse avec depuis quelques jours je la
teste tu vois je fais plein de trucs
avec mais j'aimerais bien avoir d'avis
de de confrères de copains savoir ce que
le retour quoi tu en penses quoi toi
déjà ça fait plaisir de voir qu'on a une
concurrente assez crédible je trouve au
skin deck avec un peu plus d'avantages
mais également un peu plus inconvénient
alors les avantages c'est que on a autre
chose que le store de Steam on a la
possibilité de jouer à nos jeux sur le
gamepass ce soit en local ou sur le
Cloud la possibilité de jouer à des jeux
qui viennent d'autres stores comme
notamment si vous êtes abonné au pestnow
on a des inconvénients c'est quoi
pourquoi les inconvénients alors
l'autonomie c'est vraiment quelque chose
que je trouve assez rédhibitoire surtout
pour le prix de la console moi j'ai
l'habitude de jouer en 1080p 120 Hertz
et
le max c'est le max on peut jouer aussi
en 720p 60 hertz quand je joue en 1080p
120 Hertz à des jeux triple A comme GTA
V j'arrive à 1h max voir 1h30
d'autonomie à plus typiquement
aujourd'hui là on est à Munich
ce matin je suis passé de 100% à 50%
dans l'avion en une demi-heure sur GTA V
d'accord ok si vous allez m'installer un
des meilleurs jeux sur cette console
vous n'avez pas envie de devoir diminuer
la résolution juste parce que la console
ne tient pas la batterie c'est à dire
que vous devez toujours avoir à portée
de main votre blog de charge 65 watts
l'autonomie diminue drastiquement très
rapidement et pour une console portable
pour moi c'est pas du tout acceptable
silencieux ce qui veut dire que ça
consomme un peu moins d'énergie mon plus
gros souci là-dessus ça va être sur tout
l'autonomie
de mes tests tournent notre entre 1h
pour les grands jeux faire les jeux qui
consomment beaucoup et trois heures pour
les jeux qui consomment pas du tout en
passant de 100 % en passant de 100%
minimum après le point positif et cette
console est extrêmement performante donc
vous allez pouvoir faire tourner tous
les jeux que vous voulez vous pouvez lui
en mettre dans la tronche ça bronche pas
mais par contre il vous faut ça avec
vous et ça c'est quand même très relou
et puis troisième point non des moindres
bien je trouve trop cher cette console
alors certains diront attends 800 balles
vous avez une des consoles portatives
elle est forcément plus cher qu'un stand
deck mais pour autant vous allez faire
tourner des jeux plus puissants dessus
et elle est très cool je suis d'accord
avec vous sauf que il faut une fois de
plus le remettre en perspective à qui
elle s'adresse cette console elle
s'adresse pour moi cette console à tous
ceux qui veulent jouer sur PC mais avec
un PC qu'on peut emmener partout avec
soi et avec un PC qui soit pas un PC
portable donc en fait vous avez une
console qui n'est pas réellement une
console qui cache son nom qui est un PC
portable pour tous les gamers qui
veulent jouer sur PC donc c'est vraiment
fait je pense pour les les joueurs PC
qui s'y qui s'y connaissent et qui ont
envie de bidouiller un peu alors vous me
direz ok un PC portable à 800 balles ça
reste quand même un tarif qui est
correct je suis d'accord avec vous sauf
que ça vient réduire drastiquement la
cible parce que on connaît les arcs
corps gamer on connaît les cowal gamer
sur PC maintenant vous avez les joueurs
PC plutôt que duol qui vont être sur une
interface console alors qu'il joue sur
un PC ça veut donc dire que on vient une
fois de plus réduire drastiquement la
cible on vient toucher une minorité de
personnes sur un marché qui je pense
aujourd'hui n'est pas complètement
mature comme il est en l'état avec ce
typologie de produit alors à la question
faut-il venir acheter cette rogalie
aujourd'hui à son lancement en 2023 et
bien pour moi la réponse c'est non je ne
peux pas du tout venir vous recommander
cette console à moins que vous ayez
toujours une prise à côté de vous à
moins que vous acceptez de venir
descendre la résolution et le nom
d'image par seconde de votre console
pour gagner un peu en autonomie à moins
que vous aimiez bidouiller sur Windows
et que le fait de venir chercher votre
clavier à droite à gauche quand vous
avez besoin ne soit pas un problème mais
si vous n'êtes pas dans un de ces cas de
figure je vais remettre aujourd'hui un
petit peu moins de 800 euros dans la
première console signée Asus c'est pour
moi une erreur j'aime bien ce produit
j'aime bien les promesses qu'il fait
mais faudrait-il encore qu'il puisse les
tenir et aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas il
y a des choses qui te plaisent quand
même cette console tu l'aimes bien ou
pas la possibilité de jouer
à pas mal de titres sur des titres Xbox
des petites PC des titres PlayStation
alors que sur le Cloud malheureusement
si elle avait une heure voire deux
heures de plus d'autonomie tu dirais
beaucoup
et là tu dis pas bon quoi je dis pas
beaucoup je peux pas recommander une
console à ce prix là avec une autonomie
de deux heures donc je suis pas
extrêmement convaincu bon si il vous
intéresse quand même je vous mets un
lien dans la description mais au-delà de
ça peut-être qu'il va falloir attendre
un peu plus tard ou voir la deuxième
version de Asus est-ce qu'ils arriveront
à venir corriger ces différents points
l'autonomie l'expérience a rendu Windows
un peu plus invisible allez savoir
lorsque vous en pensez vous est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi sur le fait
que cette console elle a beau être cool
il y a des choses qui vont pas
marquez-moi ça bien évidemment dans les
commentaires et nous on se retrouve très
bientôt pour continuer à parler de texte
plein d'autres choses ça c'est cool
bisous Ciao